françois mitterrand a visité ce matin le
chantier de la tête défense dont l'arche
gigantesque plus de 100 mètres de côté
marquera l'achèvement la construction de
cette arche avance au rythme d'un étage
tous les quatre jours
on en est maintenant aux deux tiers de
la hauteur définitive les gens pirro
kerry était ce matin sur le chantier
sans se mettre de côté 70 mètres de
profondeur notre dame toute entière avec
sa flèche tiendrait à l'intérieur de la
grande arche de la défense
les deux parois verticales haute de 35
étages sont aujourd'hui terminés pour le
gros oeuvre leur gigantesque carcasse
qui s'élève dans le ciel nous donne
encore qu'une idée assez vague de ce que
sera le monument une fois achevé le
chantier titanesque emploie plus de 2000
personnes
l'ensemble de l'ouvragé pèsera à terme
300 mille tonnes avec une prochaine
étape qui sera déterminante et
constituera un formidable défi technique
maintenant il nous reste à faire le
morceau de bravoure construire le toit
de l'arche et nous allons commencer
avant sur le toit de l'arche à partir de
l'été vers la fin du mois de juin la
dernière semaine du mois de juin
on va monter à 110 mètres de haut un
grand portique sur lequel on va couler
la première poutre de 100 mètres de long
qui 70 m de portée
imaginez une poutre qui traversera les
champs elysées à son mètre d'eau
difficile à concevoir cette structure
fabuleuse par son gigantisme doit être
travaillé comme un bijou
elle sera revêtue de marbre blanc ou
gris chaque plaque de marbre de carrare
et tailles et numérotée sur place de
manière à conserver une vanne identique
ainsi j'aurai nioto vent ce préquel
scène aujourd'hui disparu et son
architecte associé paul andreu ont ils
réalisé ce dont rêvait dit-on déjà
colbert parfaire la perspective tracée
par le nôtre à partir de la cour carrée
du louvre